we're trying to do approximations of
solutions right you get some function
and it's not a quadratic or something
nice and neat you know that there's a
solution there's a root
somewhere okay but because it's not the
kinds of functions that we know how to
deal with
you can't work it out precisely okay but
we can get very close
right so the first method we used was
the bisection method
or halving the interval and like we said
it was very very simple
okay um in fact when you think about it
a function
right and having a method what kind of
level of understanding do you need to
have
like what kind of mathematical chops do
you need to be able to do that kind of
method
um well you need to know what a function
is okay um you need to be able to
substitute
stuff into that function you need to be
able to
halve intervals okay so take averages of
numbers
you think about when could you do that
um maybe all the way back to say your
rate
or united's gonna be really conservative
i think even if you don't understand
what you're doing
you can teach a year eight or nine the
bisection method and they can get
they can go through the steps and it'll
it'll work okay
um but because it's so simple um you
remember it's it's quite slow like it
took quite
a few sort of steps to get any kind of
level of reasonable accuracy
okay so that's why we're getting on the
newton's method okay now newton's method
is smarter
right uh that means it's a little bit
harder but it means it's a lot more
accurate a lot more quickly
okay so what i'll do is i'll show it to
you i want you to get this down in your
diagram
i'll show you the mechanics of how it
works first and then we'll look at the
actual
algebra and how we're going to crunch it
out okay
so here's where you start you've got
your function and you know there's
a solution somewhere okay so you take a
guess
and you need to make sure your guess is
nearby okay for similar reasons as with
bisection but you can't just pick any
values you like
i'll give you some counter examples
shortly but suppose we pick a spot like
here
now we'll make that my first guess so
i'll call that x
one right so that's kind of
like in the ballpark right so what i do
with this
is uh similar to um the way i did with
bisection method i'm going to evaluate
the function at that point
okay so if i evaluate it i get this
i have this point up here right now what
will its coordinates be
just quickly where's it going to be at x
coordinate is
x1 what's its y coordinate
okay good so far so good but now here's
where newton's method gets really really
um
clever okay how are we going to use this
guess
to get closer to the root well
um i told you well did i mention
yesterday the newton's method
involves calculus okay so this is not
something a year nine could do okay you
need to be able to
have a function which you can
differentiate so this is a little more
narrow it doesn't work for all functions
but you know how to differentiate tons
of functions okay
so if i can differentiate this right i
can know the gradient of that point
more helpfully to me geometrically i can
find the equation of the tangent that
goes through there
okay now why would a tangent be useful
to me
well i'm trying to find a root right i'm
trying to find a solution to this
equation
if you draw in the tangent at that point
at your guess
okay what's it going to look like well
let's see how well can i draw this
that's kind of close okay there's a
tangent that goes through we can find
out the equation of this
we've been doing this for months right
so there's my equation
now what's useful about it is that where
this tangent intersects
with the x-axis okay that's going to be
closer
to the root than my original guess okay
shouldn't be further away i mean in this
example you can see quite clearly we're
getting closer
okay so i'm going to call this second
point down here right i'll take this
tangent right i'll need to get its
equation and when i
solve it for y equals zero right
that'll give me another guess x2 okay
now that i'm close up i'll repeat the
process okay
so i'll evaluate it again that'll give
me this point up here
and its coordinates will be x2
f of x2 okay
and then i find the tangent through
there again right
so now my tangent will be let's see here
something a little like that right so
now i have a third guess
and you can see it gets pretty close
pretty quick because of the nature of
the tangent
right the idea of the tangent is and
often um in some textbooks or you'll
hear some people say
you're kind of like sliding down the
tangent towards an approximation
okay and because the tangent is not just
you know bisecting is just
random it's like well halfway i don't
know like maybe that's good
but you see the tangent is quite
thoughtful it's like right this should
be getting me closer
towards there okay now it's worth
noticing that if you've got a graph
you've got a curve and it's not concave
up right it'll look a little different
so on the side of this draw yourself
another curve
let's draw this one concave down okay
it'll still work but because of the way
the tangent goes you'll see
it's not going to be quite so neat still
works but
so actually i'm going to need a little
more of this
now if i take a guess again let's take
it to the right okay
so let's guess over here x1 right so i
evaluate
i'm going to be up here now draw your
tangent in but because you're concave
down
your tangent's now going to flip over to
the other side
of the roof that you're after okay so if
i draw this here it'll be something like
this
yeah thereabouts so i'm kind of overshot
right
but because it's a tangent assuming it's
a tangent at a good spot and we
will talk about what good spots and bad
spots are in a minute
because it's a tangent it should be
closer still right
so my next guess even though it's on the
other side
i can still repeat this process right i
haven't quite drawn my graph very well
so sort of mine
drops off but you know you can go down
here and when you draw your new tangent
the new change it will still be closer
right it'll be something like you know i
don't know
something like that okay so there's
going to be my x3
and you can see it gets super close
super fast okay it's a great method
right okay so regardless of where to
concave up or concave down
how do you do the actual maths of it how
does newton's method
actually work
okay
so in order to uh go from one guest to
another
what kinds of things do i need well i've
been talking about the tangent right
and i said to go from this one to this
one i'm gonna have to solve the equation
of the tangent when y is equal to zero
so i need the equation of the tangent
right i know the point that it goes
through
okay so what's its gradient what is the
gradient at this point remember i
i haven't told you what the function is
i've just said it's some function so how
would you
express write down the gradient at that
point
yeah good at this particular spot
right if you differentiate and then you
put in your x1
okay that'll give you the gradient right
so now i know what this equation of this
first tangent will be
okay um do point gradient form so you're
going to have y
minus y one so i should have said um
i should have said what this is this is
the tangent at
x equals x one okay so it'll be y
minus y y1 is that
f of x1
that's equal to m outside of x minus x1
okay so there's our
m f dash
and x minus now conveniently my x one is
x one okay so good there's the equation
of my tangent
all right now remember what i'm going to
solve is when does this tangent collide
with the x-axis that's where x2 is
okay so therefore this point here right
is actually
x2 0. so i'll take those two
coordinates and i'll put them in x
will equal x2 right and
y will equal 0. okay
so to find x2
i'll sub those in okay i'll say y is
equal to 0
that's that there's the gradient
but this part here is x2 that's what i'm
after okay
minus x1 so that's a bit messy let's
just tighten it up
i'm trying to find x2 so let's just make
that the subject
okay so the first thing i can probably
do is divide through
by the gradient that gives me this
that'll leave me with x2 minus x1
on this side so now when i make x to the
subject
that'll become positive on the other
side
uh sorry and that's still minus
ta-da okay so if i know
one guess i can go to the next one and
you can see if i wanted to do
the one after that or x3 would just be
take the previous x-coordinate that you
got the previous guess that you
generated now the way that a lot of
people remember
this right and they just proceed from
there is that this bit on the right hand
side what does it look like
looks familiar doesn't it
looks like a derivative you're familiar
with right this is sort of like
chain rule for log functions right
because when you differentiate
log of some function okay
you get what you get f
dash on f so that's a bit tricky see
this is upside down the f dash is on the
bottom
i had to divide through that because
this is where it was i need to get on
the other side
okay did anyone think of where newton's
method breaks down
so newton's method relies on calculus
right and it relies on
tangents okay so if you find if you if
you have a guess
right that's close to a place where the
tangent is going to lead you somewhere
else
then you trouble okay so um if you're on
a stationary point it's game over
okay because what you'll have is you
know there's the roots and there's a
stationary point okay say up here
so if you're like i'm trying to find
this route forget about the opposite
actually
if you pick the stationary point you're
like okay let's put the tangent in it
goes
and you will never have an x2 because
there isn't it never collides with the
axis right
but more generally because we generally
know where the um where stationary
points are so we don't guess them right
if you guess near a stationary point
you're still in trouble okay so draw
this for me
okay suppose you have this kind of
function
which is not that hard to imagine really
and what we're trying to find
is this root here okay now you'd
probably think okay i just want to be
nearby i just want to be in the
neighborhood okay
so suppose i pick a point like here
there's my first guess well you can see
because of where i picked it right
you're going to have some problems right
because when i draw up
right and evaluate
that's where i want to draw a tangent
through and because i'm so close to the
stationary point
right it's not going to come back to the
axis and get closer to the root very
quickly
in fact it's it's going to be your
tangent will be so shallow
that it's going to go not just further
away
but closer to another root okay the
interesting
thing is once you get this point
newton's method still
sort of works you still arrive at
something but you won't arrive at where
you want it to end right
because as you continue with your next
guess well actually in this case
it's gonna be somewhere up there so your
next guest will be
you know down like that wherever it
lands okay so you're still going to
approach a root
it'll just be this one not that one okay
so
with newton's method just like with
bisection method
people don't generally mess up the
actual calculations because very
straightforward very you know
repetitive but where people trip up is
in the selection of their guesses
okay so as a bisection method make sure
you pick one that's close enough
so that you don't end up omitting roots
okay
within reason yeah so yeah like i said
often they'll give you x1
but if you have to pick it you need to
pick it nearby
you can see if i picked it over here i
mean i'm giving more trouble right
because i'm going further away not
closer